you
you
the path to building super intelligence
requires us to unlock the most
fundamental secrets of the universe
intelligent machines will soon allow us
to compare our most intractable
challenges to develop new methods for
the early detection of cancer take all
the better future for all of us simply
put to save lives
once online its analytical power will be
greater and the collective intelligence
of every person born in the history of
the world professor
independence we're looking at five weeks
friend they don't know the danger
she connected to the Internet the first
thing it'll do is copy itself and then
there is no taking it down the real will
died whatever it is building an army out
there it's evolution this isn't
devolution is an abomination what else
happened I may be fixed
come to Fargo stopping I don't
understand this is the future not here
with me
have you fallen out of love with me
Avia if we don't stop him it will be the
end of mankind as we know it
you